E
REFERRING TO HIS LIFE IS A
DUBIOUS GIMMICK.
HE WAS REACTION FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, MIKE PENCE IS
BACK WITH US.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
I'D LIKE TO HAVE A ADULTS BACK
IN ACTION AND WORKING.
THAT WOULD BE GOOD.
LET ME START WITH THIS QUESTION.
DID YOU EVER IMAGINE IN OUR
LIFETIME THAT WE WOULD EVER SEE
A PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I KNOW THAT YOU WOULDN'T DO IT.
I KNOW DONALD TRUMP WOULDN'T DO
IT.
MIKE POMPEO WOULDN'T DO IT.
ABANDON FELLOW AMERICANS 13 DAYS
AFTER PROMISING THAT HE WOULDN'T
ABANDON ANY AMERICANS?
DID YOU EVER SEE THAT HAPPENING?
>> LET ME BE CLEAR ON THIS
POINT.
FOR YOUR VIEWERS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S
DISASTROUS WITHDRAWAL FROM
AFGHANISTAN WAS THE GREATEST
FOREIGN POLICY DEBACLE SINCE THE
IRAN HOSTAGE CRISIS AND IT NEVER
HAD TO HAPPEN.
THE DEAL THAT OUR ADMINISTRATION
NEGOTIATED ACTUALLY WAS FINISHED
IN FEBRUARY OF 2020.
THAT WAS A MATTER OF WEEKS AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP GIVEN THE ORDER
TO TAKE OUT QASSEM SOLEIMANI.
IT WAS JUST A FEW MONTHS AFTER
WE HAD ELIMINATED THE ISIS
CALIPHATE AND TAKEN DOWN ALBERT
AL-BAGHDADI.
KEEPING THE DEAL TO WORK WITH
THE AFGHAN GOVERNMENT, NOT
HARMING ANY AMERICAN PERSONNEL
IN AFGHANISTAN AND NOT THE ASSAY
OF FOR TERRORISTS OR WE WOULD
HIT THEM HARDER THAN WE EVER HIT
THEM BEFORE.
WE WENT 18 MONTHS WITHOUT A
SINGLE AMERICAN CASUALTY IN
AFGHANISTAN.
WEAKNESS AROUSES EVIL, SEAN, AND
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THE
WEAKNESS EVIDENCED BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION I WOULD SAY
BEGINNING WHEN THEY WERE SILENT
WHEN THOUSANDS OF ROCKETS WERE
RAIN DOWN ON OUR CHERISHED ALLY
ISRAEL FROM HAMAS SENT SIGNAL
INTO AFGHANISTAN THAT WE WOULD
NOT RESPOND.
YOU SAW, AS YOU SAW IT EARLIER
YOU SAW THE TALIBAN MARCH IN AND
WALK INTO KABUL.
I REALLY WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW
THAT I BELIEVE WITH ALL MY HEART
THAT THIS NEVER HAD TO HAPPEN.
I WOULD GRIEVE FOR THE 13
SERVICE MEMBERS WHO WERE LOST.
KAREN AND I PRAYED AND SPENT
TIME WITH THE FAMILY OF CORPORAL
HUMBERTO SANCHEZ FROM INDIANA.
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO SAY IT BUT
IT JUST DIDN'T HAVE TO HAPPEN.
IT'S AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT WEAK
LEADERSHIP MEANS ON THE WORLD
STAGE AND IT'S SUCH A CONTRAST
TO THE HEAVY HANDED LEADERSHIP
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION AT HOME.
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO IS WEAK
ABROAD BUT VERY CONTENT TO BE
LECTURING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ABOUT VACCINE MANDATES.
ATTEMPTING TO DRIVE THROUGH THE
CONGRESS WOULD BE NOT JUST THE
LARGEST SPENDING BILL IN HISTORY
THE COUNTRY, IT WOULD BE THE
LARGEST TAX INCREASE IN THE
HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY.
THE JOINT TAXATION COMMITTEE IN
CONGRESS THAT IT WOULD RAISE
TAXES IN JUST A MATTER OF A FEW
YEARS ON AMERICANS WHO MAKE OVER
$40,000 A YEAR.
WE HAVE GOT TO DIG IN, TELL THE
STORY OF WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
I TRULY DO BELIEVE THAT THE
VOICE OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN
TURN BACK THIS MASSIVE BIG
GOVERNMENT SOCIALIST BILL.
I AM DOING MY LEVEL BEST.
>> Sean: I WANT TO STAY ON ONE
ISSUE AND I HAVE THIS CONFIRMED
BY SECRETARY OF STATE POMPEO AND
MARK MEADOWS AND OTHERS.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE HEARD THE
CALLS AND IF YOU DID, WHAT YOU
COULD SHARE WITH US.
BEFORE ANY DEAL WAS EVER
DISCUSSED, IN TERMS OF AMERICA'S
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN,
THAT IT WAS VERY CLEAR BY THE
PRESIDENT, DONALD TRUMP, THAT IF
THEY DON'T FOLLOW EVERY PERIOD,
COMMA, DOTTED I AND CROSSED T,
HE SAID HE WOULD OBLITERATE THEM
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
CONDITIONS ON A GROUND-BASED
WITHDRAWAL, INCLUDED AMERICA
KEEPING BAGRAM AIRBASE FOREVER.
STRATEGICALLY IMPORTANT
LOCATION.
AND THAT IN FACT IT WAS SAID
OVER AND OVER AGAIN, WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE CALIPHATE,
SOLEIMANI, AL-BAGHDADI AND
ASSOCIATES, THE AL QAEDA LEADER
IN YEMEN WILL HAPPEN TO YOU.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND?
DID YOU HEAR THOSE CALLS?
THE GUY WAS STANDING ACROSS THE
RESOLUTE DESK FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN HE TALKED
ON THE SPEAKERPHONE TO THE TALIN
IN FEBRUARY 2020.
HE SAID WE ALL WANT TO END THE
VIOLENCE.
I SHARE THE CONVICTION THAT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF AMERICANS
BELIEVE THAT WE WANTED TO GET
OUR TROOPS HOME.
BUT WE WANTED TO DO IT WITH
HONOR.
WE WANTED TO DO IT IN AN ORDERLY
WAY AND WE WANTED TO LEAVE
BEHIND THE KIND OF CONDITIONS
THAT WOULD BE REFLECTIVE OF THE
ENORMOUS SERVICE AND SACRIFICE
OF OUR TROOPS OVER THE LAST 20
YEARS.
THE PRESIDENT MADE IT CLEAR.
HE SAID IF YOU BREAK THIS DEAL,
WE ARE GOING TO HIT YOU HARDER
THAN WE'VE EVER HIT YOU BEFORE.
HE SAID I DON'T LIKE SAYING THAT
BUT HE SAID, I JUST WANT YOU TO
KNOW.
I COULD HEAR IN THE VOICE.
HE KNEW PRESIDENT TRUMP MEANT
BUSINESS.
THEY MOVED THE DATE FOR THE
WITHDRAWAL BEYOND THE SPRING AND
INTO THE FIGHTING SEASON, SAYING
SEPTEMBER 11TH.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, THE IDEA
THAT WE ABANDON BAGRAM AIRBASE
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT
WITHOUT TELLING HER ALLIES AND
WORST OF ALL THAT WE LEFT
AMERICANS OF AMERICAN ALLIES
BEHIND WAS UNCONSCIONABLE.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, THE GENERALS
OF EVENT TESTIFY BEFORE THE
CONGRESS, THE FOCUS ON THE
ADVICE TO PRESIDENT GOD, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THE BOOK
STOPS THE PRESIDENT'S DESK.
THE PEOPLE IN THE DAYS AHEAD,
WEEKS AHEAD, ELECTIONS AHEAD ARE
GOING TO HOLD JOE BIDEN
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR DISASTROUS
WITHDRAWAL.
CAN I SAY ONE MORE THING?
NOTHING OF THE CURRENT COMMANDER
IN CHIEF'S FAILINGS IN
AFGHANISTAN AND I WANT TO SAY
THIS FROM MY HEART, TO EVERY
VETERAN WHO SERVED THERE AND THE
FAMILIES OF OUR FALLEN, NOTHING
OF THE DISASTROUS WITHDRAWAL I'M
AFGHANISTAN BY JOE BIDEN WILL
EVER DIMINISH THE SERVICE AND
SACRIFICE OF ALL OF OUR
SERVICE MEMBERS OVER THE LAST 20
YEARS WHO WENT TO AFGHANISTAN
AND DEFENDED OUR FREEDOM.
THEY WILL BE HONORED FOREVER IN
THE ANNALS OF THE HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY AND GOD BLESS THEM
ALL.
>> Sean: A LOOK AT THEIR
SUCCESS, THE POLICY SUCCESS.
THE TRUMP-PENCE ADMINISTRATION.
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS, THE
LOWEST LEGAL IMMIGRATION ANIMALS
40 YEARS STAY IN MEXICO POLICY
WORKED.
WHILE BUILDING WORK.
ELIMINATING CATCH AND RELEASE.
NOW IT'S PROCESS ON RELEASE.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A 30-YEAR
RECORD OF OPEN BORDERS, PROCESS,
RELEASE.
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE, LOWER
TAXES, LESS BUREAUCRACY.
THE ECONOMY WAS BOOMING.
RECORD LOW ON EMPLOYMENT FOR
EVERY DEMOGRAPHIC GROUP IN THE
COUNTRY.
FREE AND FAIR TRADE.
NATO PAYING THEIR FAIR SHARE.
THE WORLD BELIEVED THAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WOULD USE
FORCE APPROPRIATELY WHEN NEEDED
AND THERE WAS A GENUINE FEAR.
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH WORKED.
AS YOU LOOK BACK ON ALL OF THESE
ISSUES, ALL OF THIS NOW IN NINE
MONTHS HAS DISAPPEARED.
I KNEW IT WOULD BE BAD.
I TRIED TO WARN PEOPLE.
I DIDN'T THINK WOULD BE THIS BAD
THIS FAST.
>> YOU TOOK THE WORDS OUT OF MY
MOUTH, SEAN.
I KNEW IT WOULD BE BAD.
WE WORKED OUR HEARTS OUT IN THAT
CAMPAIGN LAST YEAR.
BUT I DIDN'T KNOW IT WILL BE
THIS BAD.
THE TRUTH IS FROM THE VERY FIRST
DAY OF THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING TO
UNRAVEL AND UNDO ALL OF THE
POLICIES THAT RESULTED IN A
STRONGER, MORE SECURE, MORE
PROSPEROUS AMERICA.
THIS LATEST MASSIVE BILL THAT
THEY ARE TRYING TO FORCE THROUGH
TO CONGRESS IS JUST THE LATEST
EXAMPLE OF THAT.
WE CUT TAXES ON WORKING FAMILIES
AND SMALL BUSINESSES AND CREATED
7 MILLION GOOD PAYING JOBS.
WE BUILT 400 MILES OF
BORDER WALL AND NEGOTIATED WITH
MEXICO ON THE REMAINING MEXICO
AGREEMENT TO REDUCE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION BY 90%.
NOW WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
WORST BORDER CRISIS IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
ON MY PODCAST THAT WE RECORDED
TODAY, I TALKED TO RODNEY SCOTT,
CHIEF OF THE BORDER PATROL UNTIL
ABOUT FIVE MONTHS AGO.
HE SAID LITERALLY FROM
ELECTION DAY FORWARD, THE
RHETORIC COMING OUT OF THE
BIDEN-HARRIS TEAM WAS
EMBOLDENING THE CARTELS,
EMBOLDENING PEOPLE TO BEGIN THE
LONG AND DANGEROUS JOURNEY NORTH
TO OUR BORDER.
THE CRISIS THAT YOU SEE TODAY IS
A RESULT OF THEM UNRAVELING ARE
POLICIES THAT WERE WORKING AT
THE BORDER AND THE MESSAGES
THEY'VE BEEN SENDING SOUTH OF
THE BORDER.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU, ON ONE ISSUE
AFTER ANOTHER, I AM ABSOLUTELY
CONVINCED THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE CAN SEE THAT IN OUR
ADMINISTRATION, WE ARE PUTTING
COMMON SENSE, CONSERVATIVE
PRINCIPLES INTO PRACTICE.
OUR NATION, OUR BORDER WAS MORE
SECURE.
OUR ECONOMY MORE PROSPEROUS, OUR
LIBERTIES MORE SECURE WITH 300
JUDGES IN OUR SUPREME COURT --
ON OUR COURTS AND THREE ON THE
SUPREME COURT AND NOW THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN SEE THIS BIG
GOVERNMENT SOCIALIST AGENDA
WRIT LARGE, OPEN BORDERS, HIGHER
TAXES, A WEEKEND APOLOGETIC
FOREIGN POLICY THAT I'VE GOT TO
TELL YOU, I KNOW WE HAVE A
COUPLE ELECTIONS THIS FALL IN
PLACES LIKE VIRGINIA AND
NEW JERSEY.
WE HAVE GOT SOME BIG ELECTIONS
AND I THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET
IT ALL BACK.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE
OUR RECORD, THEY SEE THEIR
RECORD OF LIBERALISM AND
INCOMPETENCE.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO TAKE THE REINS ENTERING
THIS COUNTRY AROUND.
WE ARE GOING TO WIN BACK THE
CONGRESS IN 2022 OF THEM ARE
GOING TO WIN BACK AMERICA 2024.
>> Sean: I KNOW A LOT OF IT
MADE OVER THE DISAGREEMENT WITH
THE PRESIDENT AS A RELEASE
JANUARY 6TH.
MY SOURCES, MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT YOU TWO HAVE A STRONG
RELATIONSHIP TO THIS DAY.
WHEN IS YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE PRESIDENT?
>> YOU CAN'T SPEND ALMOST FIVE
YEARS IN THE POLITICAL FOXHOLE
WITH SOMEBODY WITHOUT DEVELOPING
A STRONG RELATIONSHIP.
JANUARY 6 WAS A TRAGIC DAY IN
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
BUT THANKS TO THE EFFORTS OF THE
CAPITOL HILL POLICE, FEDERAL
OFFICIALS, THE CAPITOL WAS
SECURED AND WE FINISHED OUR
WORK.
THE PRESIDENT AND I SAT DOWN A
FEW DAYS LATER AND TALKED
THROUGH ALL OF IT.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT WE PARTED
AMICABLY AT THE END OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WE HAVE
TALKED A NUMBER OF TIMES SINCE
WE BOTH LEFT OFFICE.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT OUR ENTIRE
FOCUS TODAY SHOULD BE ON THE
FUTURE.
I HAVE CAMPAIGNED A COUPLE TIMES
FOR GLENN YOUNGKIN, WILL BE A
GREAT GOVERNOR FOR THE STATE OF
VIRGINIA.
I'VE BEEN TRAVELING ALL ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY HELPING OUR TEAM
RUNNING FOR THE HOUSE AND
SENATE.
I'LL BE HAPPENING GOVERNOR'S
CANDIDATES THROUGHOUT AMERICA.
I KNOW THE MEDIA WANTS TO
DISTRACT FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S FAILED AGENDA
BY FOCUSING ON ONE DAY IN
JANUARY.
THEY WILL USE THAT ONE DAY TO
TRY TO DEMEAN THE CHARACTER AND
INTENTIONS OF 74 MILLION
AMERICANS WHO BELIEVED WE COULD
BE STRONG AGAIN AND PROSPEROUS
AGAIN AND SUPPORTED OUR
ADMINISTRATION IN 2016 AND 2020.
FOR OUR PART, I TRULY BELIEVE WE
ALL OUGHT TO REMAIN COMPLETE THE
FOCUS ON THE FUTURE.
THAT'S WHERE I'M FOCUSED.
>> Sean: I WANT TO COMMISSION
ALSO ON THE 534 RIOTS THAT TOOK
PLACE IN 2020.
THE ONES WHERE KAMALA HARRIS WAS
PROMOTING BAIL FUNDS TO GET THE
RIOTERS OUT THAT KILLED DOZENS
OF AMERICANS, INJURED THOUSANDS
OF POLICE OFFICERS PELTED WITH
BRICKS, ROCKS, BOTTLES AND